but that that brave moment when you
decide that now it's the time to propose
oh my god what what what
happened there well cherry's parents
never married
so they were together for 30 years
they're now they've now married by the
way but they they were together for 30
years so she hasn't grown up in
thinking that marriage is important but
i've come from a
that sort of thing and my parents are
married their parents are married and
blah blah so i was walking into it being
like i don't know if she's going to say
yes there wasn't like a
you know the confidence of being like
hey oh my god yes so i did it so you you
really didn't know i really didn't know
i remember getting down on what i've
never told this story actually i
remember getting down on one knee
and her just being like
and i was like marry me and she was like
you're joking and i remember
there was just a just a long silence and
i just went
please
that was the most human that i've ever
felt the most because it was like in my
career sometimes i
you know you find i'd be like can i do
this and people will just be like yeah
well can i do this and yeah you kind of
get to a certain point where it just
becomes normal and then you're in a
situation where you are literally on
your knees being like
yeah and it's such a huge life decision
that someone has to make in the blink of
an eye thankfully she did say yes and uh
you know
did you have a plan b there
oh
i don't know
do you know what the the worst thing
about it was i put the date on
the ring
so i and the day and it it was pissing
it down with rain outside and i'd built
a pergola at the end of the
garden do you get to do it sun sunset go
to the pergola some wine and you're
pissing it down with rain and i kept
saying to her we should go for a walk
she's like no
you sure you don't want to go for a walk
and time's ticking time's ticking
and there's the date on the ring and i'm
like i've got to do it today because
it's like it gets to like 9 00 p.m and
what am i saying then yeah this is the
first time i've ever told this story
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe